the nits magical cycle of returning the
cold space by providing arrive to jorge
online water vibraphone and jorge is the
software in general
financed the action plan as
underworld tax of the software they want to
enter the garden or to have the best
manager of the dive in  the attempt of
our bicolor of websites that have very
travel in various neighborhoods of the grand
place to work in the ussr vivas in we
fight to work in that the government
there is still a brief review of the left
software engineering software and invoice
wallet divas the staff  expressed
idealizing I would like to leave
great work and fragile files and to be
a reform being in loreto extends he
saw it in problems
risen then in force from tecnotur and
software engineering the truth is that I
go to bed who speaks in English
now with his belly discussions this
year
English
and left by tourists on the air or the largest
as thank you very much for inviting me here to
be on your channel I really appreciate
the invitation  and well about
me my name is jorge m jorge villalobos i am a
software developer at amazon and i
also have one here on youtube my channel
is latin coder it is about software
tips and tutorials from time to time of
everything in spanish and well to me
I like dogs I like movies I
like video games from time to time
I like to play sports and I also like to
read science fiction and role-playing my
favorite authors are Isaac Asímov and Stephen
King and well I like dogs
through dogs are great and  Well,
it's a little bit about me.
Well, about my history. I've
been an engineer basically in
information technology. I studied
there in 2007 and graduated in 2011. I
started working in 2012 in this industry and
I've been developing software since
that year. I've been through technology.  web
like php or javascript I also went through
android for a while and right now it's good because
I've continued with software development
working for several companies the most
important for which I have worked
because they have possibly been intel and
currently amazon when he started
working at amazon basically because
after a whole
preparation process I consider that for me it was
basically about six months of
study I had already had experience
developing software however  I
thought that as my career objective I
wanted to work in a company that was
largely dedicated to what is
software development and that for a
company recognized for it there were
several companies in life for
which I began to prepare  all
located here in the usa
and fortunately after a long
process of interviews and travel and
study,
well, I managed to enter the
company here and the method that I used to
prepare myself was practically through
a book called cracking of young
international  video is a book
that now has advice and algorithmic problems to
solve for me
particularly  they were difficult for me it
was difficult to learn this because I
feel that I had not had a very good
preparation in canal algorithm and that I
also compensated with pages like
ranco check lipkow generally any
page where I could find
code problems solve them and upload them to
see if they were  Well that's what I was
looking to do and well apart from that I
also asked for help I asked for people to
teach me as well as give me advice
people who would interview me in order to
practice as much as possible to do
better in the interview
in fact this was my second  I try
to enter amazon and objective apart
from the attempts that he says to other
companies and that later it went much better
and really good that I am very happy
to have been here but in total it
was more than about
six months of study and well  well here
we are making it worthwhile
ok it's me and jaime experience for people
who practice or show with the white
working  day in whitehaven and in
technologies or payment online straight
go to work in this so many children in
mexico
I have approximately 7 years of
experience of which the vast
majority have been in mexico since 2012 when I
graduated for myself
go to work in mexico  It has been an
incredible experience. I have learned a
lot because I worked for companies that
are dedicated to different things. I work
for a consultancy that did not say much about
programming per se, but was more like
databases. I also worked for a
company that is dedicated to
development.  web web pages
specifically
I was working both on the download and on the
front end using php and script then
I worked for a Mexican statue where
it was also a very
interesting experience because I learned a lot a
lot very little time working with
people it's quite stupid someone
intelligent that despite the fact that
Several years have passed and I consider that they
were very good and the pace of work
was  pretty quickly in that
job
I was using imagine from a
mobile android mobile applications
to meeting kings being laws and I
learned from people who knew about
statistics for example where I didn't do
much work I didn't do
statistical work at all but I learned from
them and then  I said a little bit about the
front-end to visualize the
training they did, it was quite a
journey
like a roller coaster, I would say,
and then, well, it is in Mexico
now that some of the companies or types
of companies that there are many startups in the
city of  Mexico and Guadalajara, which are
the cities in which I
lived, there are also many large companies,
for example, there are companies I
worked for Intel, which is a
large company that is also in
Mexico, but there are other companies, for
example, in going down to 4, it is now with
how many ibm do you find hp and intel from
there he didn't mention out there and companies that
are also dedicated to the development of  e
software there are generally many
software factories because thank you and
I say I guess because of the
free trade agreement that they have with the US
Mexico because it has been a country where it is
cheaper for some companies to
develop software so that it
can be used elsewhere  then the
companies for which we have worked
on many occasions have clients
not only from mexico but also from the
united states or europe and even from
other latin american countries because they
have positioned it in mind as
a cradle of software development
even in guadalajara we say that  it is the
mexican silicon valley because
of the software development companies that have been
located there, so what
technologies do they use their learning php
javascript james android ios all that is
done development of image applications
a cloud of seen that they
use
the cloud computer  google also
microsoft facer all all that I
have not I have seen that they use them  here in
mexico in terms of latin america I
would not be so sure because
I only have the perspective of mexico but
if he is searched for example on the internet
what are the types of jobs that there are
and web development for example is
everywhere in all countries he will
there will be web development vacancies for someone
who knows how to make a web page and
even mobile applications in
all countries practically there will be
work on this with so much
density I am not very sure in other
countries but in Mexico there is a
fairly strong market
good  about coming here to the usa what
he wanted me to do or what made me
want to do this trip was basically
the opportunity to work for a
company that i think has a
strong presence in software development
for me to work for a
company in the  caliber of amazon
objective that I had for a long time
and simply to enter there to be here as
how I managed to be at this moment well
f  It was a goal accomplished in my
career, it was a new stage, and
I see that now as an opportunity that I do
have and that I think is
worth it because every day I am
learning something new,
I definitely wanted to add this to
my resume.  I wanted to add that to my
professional experience I wanted to
show that I had what it took
to work in a company like this
was difficult but wanting that and
wanting to grow my career like that was what
made me want to come here to have the
opportunity to work here with  other
engineers from the US or from other countries who
are great and learn from them
every day
and that is what I like I am
passionate about software development I am
passionate about programming and being here is
like fulfilling that dream of being able to learn
of people that I consider much more
intelligent than I don't and that I have a lot
to learn from them and this opportunity
is good that's why I'm here it's
because of the passion that I have for you  ngo
of the software development that brought me here
in uruguay and participated in mansfield
boreham interstate it is good for
english i have learned it since i was a child
really when i was little my parents
got me to have a teacher
who can give me english classes
around  I remember when I was 9 years old
and also from that age
approximately the same 910 years
I was in a school that we call
bilingual basically in
Latin American countries you will find
schools that will teach English
generally they will have teachers who
have
a very high level of English  or
even teachers who go up in English to
their native language and the subjects or
courses such as mathematics or
science are going to be taught in English
so they do not expose themselves in English
strongly at that stage so that
we learn and that is how I learned
later  when he was in
college he didn't take many
English subjects at school at the
university  d but I already brought that
knowledge from my childhood and
adolescence, so currently what I
do is try to simply do things like
watch television, watch movies without
English subtitles and that helps me
maintain the level although now
I have the opportunity to speak it almost
all the time  time because I'm living
start but well that's a tip of something
I do to stay a little
tuned in the subject especially when I
lived in Mexico where I was not exposed
to English on a daily basis
a rough minister working in state
well the adaptation part is always
something that has been difficult the first thing
that has cost me a lot of work to
adapt and that I continue to work on is
naturally the language and communication
this to put it in perspective if I
was in Mexico I was from city to
city in a city like Guadalajara and I
also studied  mexico city and there
are very particular ways of expressing yourself to
communicate with people in spanish like
that
is  as it is links what those expressions call them
and basically when you
move from one place to another where
customs change a little despite
being the same language if I had
moved to a different city and maybe I
could also have had to bring
one  adaptation phase because the
words begin to change maybe
it doesn't mean that way anymore not what it meant
and I know this because when I lived in
Colombia and I didn't move to Mexico I had to
go through an adaptation process
because many times besides
speaking the  same language because I did not
understand myself with other people and I
experienced it for a while when I was
traveling in Spain for six months studying
I did not understand myself with some people
even though it was the same language
Spanish
because it was spoken differently
different words were used now
imagine  with english in the usa where
obviously you already have the
customs factor but also the language changes
and you will already be speaking in another
language all the time for me it
was also tiring because I was not
used to doing it all day and that
obviously began to affect me
in the way I communicated with my
classmates I had to pay close
attention to what was said and is
reviewing what  that was suddenly discussed
in a meeting to ask a
colleague several times what he
had said to make sure I
understood things 100% so that is the
first thing with which I began to
struggle a bit for in this process of
adaptation the  The second thing was in the
technical aspect, obviously coming to
amazon for me was a leap in the
technical level that I had to have in order to
be able to carry out my duties.
I can tell you that I have to be
learning something every day, which
is very exciting, but  see the level
that is here I have had to
make an effort more than normal than what I
considered mom to be able to catch up
with my classmates and he started
doing a  a daily struggle but little by
little to advance well, it
is very comforting when you feel
that you are already starting to do things that already
have value for the team but getting
there is being difficult it has been a bit
difficult and well I think it is part of the
adaptation because  doing this also goes
hand in hand with communication it's not the
same adapting and rapping am well in the
same language than if you're doing it in
another language then everything is connected
work wear to leave yucatán
wire well now deal with the issue of
visas  it's super complicated but
basically they are a piece of paper a document
a kind of permit that a country grants you
to enter to be able to visit it if
you are not from this country the usa is a country
for which other countries require a
visa a permit so that you can access
go to  enter the country in an alleged way
and there are views of various types
of tourism services reviewed, this one for
students, there are work visas among
other types of visas, so for a
For example, in my case, I
have both Mexican and
Colombian nationality. Well, I had different
options. Mexicans and Canadians
can apply for a special visa
called friendship, which is the
free trade agreement that exists between these
three trafficking countries.
north american free trade can apply for
a tm visa having, for example, a
university degree and being from certain
professions working in certain
industries such as the
technology industry to come to work in the us
and the requirements are not so many and it is
easier to obtain this  visa that in other
countries in my case I obtained the visa as a
Colombian you have to apply a
visa called h 1b which is basically good
because it is a lottery that you enter
and basically you also need to have a
university degree and have some
experience to be able to apply  to that
visa
and there are other options such
as the visa l one that seems to me to be
a visa that can  Basically, if you
work for a company that has
offices in different countries and the same
company has offices in the United States,
maybe that company, after spending
some time with them, can
transfer you from one country to another, and this may
be the case that  they transfer from the country that
you are that you find yourself in the US
then that is another method that exists or
the other option that it gives us they corroborated
because I personally want them to have told me it
may be an option and we have to
investigate it but it is to come as a
student and later  Since you are
studying here, they are looking for the possibility of
obtaining a work permit, but of
course you always have to investigate all of this
with a lawyer, and I
can confirm because immigration laws
can be very extensive, they
can be changing, so you always
have to look for someone.  to help you
so that you can better understand the whole
process you as an individual who
simply comes to work
I recommend that i  Investigate what
the options are and look for a company that will
help you with these immigration procedures when it
comes to offering you a
job opportunity for Huelva and following your team,
Tica Morgan played, since not even Wards, what
advice could you give for those
people who want to come to work?
here the usa and especially in technology
the first after that when you are
speaking english or for mastery of
english keep in mind that the
important thing is to communicate tennis and you
can handle a conversation
is enough don't be afraid to
try to start taking interviews if
you  English is not perfect it is not a
native level English but as long as you can
defend and maintain a
technical conversation even if you speak a little slowly
even if you speak with some mistakes but if
you can make it understood then you are on
the other side forward the second type
is that you know  very well what the
requirements are or at least investigate them
a little so that you can apply for a
dep visa  Depending on your country, there may be
different types of visas that are
worth investigating. In my case, for example, you
may have applied for a TM visa that
is only available for Mexico and
Canada, but there is also another view, such
as the H 1B CTA, which can be used
to  work here in the usa and which
has other requirements so you have to
know them to investigate them so that he
is aware that you need this
can vary depending on your country and
even the type of professional
you dedicate yourself to
the third type that I am going to give you for
When you want to
come to work with the United States, which is something
very personal,
you have to be very clear about the type of
company you want to come to work for.
Generally, there will be companies like
the ones that, well, the ones that I wanted to join,
which are companies, large companies that help you.
with all the
migratory processes and companies that have a certain
recognition that you know that there will be
that possibility and that they will support
you so that you can  working with them
and carrying out all the necessary processes,
I would recommend looking for companies of this type,
but there are also a wide
variety of companies that try to
provide sponsorship and that help
you to come here following a
visa process, so you have to look
companies that give these sponsorships does not
have to be the biggest or the best
of all, it
simply has to be something that you are
passionate about even if you really want to do it
because when you come here you come with a
commitment
to stay for a certain time because when
an investment is being made in you  and
basically all that relocation all
that is a bet that must
be worthwhile so investigate which
are the companies that you would be
interested in working for and that is also
in support of this and once you have them
well located it is time to apply well
not to be afraid it is simply another country
and miami already means that I am
also a super radical change obviously it
is a change  but we are human and we
can adapt to almost any
situation so there is no need to be
afraid of change
in family h
well on the internet you can't find my
youtube channel that the [ __ ] incoder on
my twitter which is the game and on my
instagram that  it's javi and good to
end May with many thanks
for the invitation to be here
I really appreciate it and I hope that
these answers have been
useful
efe